aha you have fallen from my trap card
because that room wasn't the room of
time at all it was a a different
functionally identical room
what this room featuring a big pendulum
and pentagram circle on the floor are
implied to be the same room Goku went
into in Dragon Ball but
I mean they are clearly not the same
room and also with this new pendulum
room situation they don't even actually
leave the room they are just training in
their minds the whole time whereas in
the original room of time Goku literally
goes down the hole into the past it
confusing to say the least but the moral
of the story here is that they are
different rooms but also
same room I don't know don't ask me I'm
not trying to get into the mind of 1980s
toei